welcome back to new rock stars I'm
Jessica Clemens and this is a breakdown
of echo episode 5 titled Mario we made
it to the finale this is the final
showdown it's done after this we last
left off in episode four with FIS pissed
that Maya didn't arrive on the plane and
his goons lost track of her Maya left
Oklahoma believing that it was the best
option for herself and her family and
we're getting ready for the Chaka Nation
Powwow in this breakdown we'll explore
what Maya's powers are if she killed the
essence of Kingpin itself and whether or
not she's a mutant no more mutants but
don't forget to check out nerd rot. shop
where right now you can find merch
inspired by the echo series including
shirt featuring the big man himself and
a shirt with Echo spelled down in ASL
with bloody knuckles grabbing a piece of
merch From Nerd Riot is a great way to
support the channel we open our final
episode of the jingle dress song by the
northern Creek then after the Marvel
Spotlight logo the drums increase then
abruptly stop to a peaceful view of the
lake by Maya's house we hear the
infamous woodpecker pecking on the tree
then Maya shoots it with a slingshot
that little serial killer she runs the
Woodpecker to her mom who I couldn't
help but notice keeps her beading set in
a chess or Checkers box my Mom leaves
her sewing stuff literally in a drawer
so every time I reach into it I stab
myself I think that's most moms her mom
also has a turtle tattoo on her arm
Turtles especially the snapping turtle
that I flagged in episode two are sacred
animals to many Native American tribes
their connection to the Earth and being
resilient protective or old creatures
but this one also just belongs to the
actress so it could mean a lot of things
AR anything to her it's just a gorgeous
tattoo and you know I love my tattoos
then we reveal the half dead woodpecker
behind the blue bandana between the blue
bandana the blue colors for stick ball
and the blue spiral the color blue must
mean something really important but I
could not find it flagging it here just
in case someone wants to screaming at me
then Maya's mom tells her of the
Woodpecker also known as the bisic the
bird that Tapped Out messages on trees
warning when enemies are approaching I
assume this was the same bird we've
previously seen but this one looks a
little different from the one below
earth the red part of its head is a
little bit taller then Maya's mom
crosses her fingers and we see her hands
light up like Maya's and she's healing
the bird this quickly cuts into a
flashback from the car crash and US
hearing the final beats of her heart a
woman who could Heal the World just dies
and that's just it's just sad this
flashback is also so significant because
Maya is remembering a good good memory
and how easily that good memory can be
overpowered by a traumatic event Chola
is checking to see if scolly has a
sewing machine or maybe even one that
she dropped off some years ago it seems
like she pawned it and in episode two
during the pre-planning to the powwow
the man mentions Chola not having a shot
for a long time after her daughter died
she did say it killed her inside and
that heartbreak probably threw Chola
into a depression unable to provide for
herself or live off the bare necessities
so she just had to pawn it luckily
Scully kept it because he clearly still
loves her then in the cutest interaction
he asked her to come back and visit
every once in a while and she prom
and it just makes me emotional then she
says until we meet again and she's out
we know now Chola needs the sewing
machine to make Maya's outfit for the
powow next we see her at the post office
in L and freaking Boh hold Kingpin is
there helping her he's keeping eyes
close on Maya's family and returning
from the plane ready to start a war it's
sweet to know that Chola keeps up with
ASL for Maya and I bet that's what the
entire family has been doing until she
returns then we catch to Maya on her
motorcycle she's outside roxon gas
roxson has made many appearances in the
MCU we see it in shehulk and the
corporation during during the fight
between obain and Tony Stark in the
first Iron Man movie it's just a massive
oil and gas company in the comics and
does a lot of illegal shady most of
the time I love that Maya throws away
the contact it only is there to appease
Fisk he should have tried to learn all
those years he's known her he'd rather
create an AI device than try that shows
that he's already a horrible dad or
uncle whatever the hell he wants to call
himself then we cut to biscuit still
alive thank god with Billy Jack handling
vender parking at the powow that's when
Zayn shows up they're absolutely
planning an ambush on the chock top
howow they're white men and they keeping
up this show then we because of who
ignores Biscuit's text until she notices
the Woodpecker who is delivering bad
news and once she realizes the
Woodpecker flies away its job is done
she speeds back to Oklahoma running with
a gun in hand to Cha's house when she
sees her mother I think a lot of the art
in this house is actually designed by
this guy I can't find the direct
connection but the art styles are very
similar and he's credited in the credits
it could also be to commemorate him
because he passed away not long ago in
2023 there's a painting behind tooa of a
woman in white red and black face paint
that sort of resembles a person during
the stickball game red symbolizes
strength black for the battle white for
peace and prosperity her mom uses her
powers for healing to go back to the
traumatic memory that may has been
holding on to since the car accident
there she tells her that she needs to
let it go because she'll always be with
her so will her ancestors the line won't
stop at echko but she'll have to fight
for her family like her ancestors did
for
her God I'm not going to cry because I'm
an idiot I believe the power is
translated so easily and it's revealed
that she's empowered by low strategy
Tuck's cunning Cha's ferocity and her
mom's love we're still learning her
powers along onside Maya it's been
mentioned by Chola and her mom that they
come when they need help so it's not
like she'll be able to use it all the
time I imagine now like is she a mutant
in the comics she also had the Phoenix
Force kind of she was also just sort of
a mimic though we're kind of strained
away from that in the series I don't
think she's a mutant I think it's more
spiritual and cultural than having that
hot X genene but it's worth mentioning
if this is spiritual she could wind up
with misto Wanda or strange so we might
be seeing some metaphysical stuff in
born again but definitely in the
Defenders because Ekko is now labeled
Under The Defenders category in Disney
plus along with the defender Saga
officially going into the MCU timeline
which is good for them I know you guys
all wanted it I wanted it so I'm very
happy about it not only does her costume
continue to have the sun rays but this
time they beam across the suit and I'll
be honest when you see an Easter egg so
often you forget to mention it the
circle Rays on ekko's coat and her dad's
neck are from the comics it's her
original outfit duh Jessica I completely
forgot the shoulders have traditional
Chaka designs the full diamonds for the
diamondb rattlesnake the spirals on the
shoulder pads the traditional hand ey
symbol represents the religious beliefs
and cosmologies of the different
historic tribes all from a then we're
back to the powwow and this booth that's
a real shop this is dancing bear Indian
Trader The Outfits during this scene are
incredible and beautiful and I know you
guys see it the folks involved
especially during the pww were a lot of
native Chu top people and the chak Cal
team that was working closely with
Marvel to make sure this was all as
authentic as possible remember how I
mentioned the Chaka princess pageant
flyer from the first episode well that's
the District 9 Junior Princess just a
beautiful group of people then we begin
the festivities not just just the Powell
but the black knife cartel ready to kill
everyone there here they come again the
white men the no holos Jing up this
episode pow's have a well respected
structure to them we begin the events
with What's called the Grand entry which
begins with the flag bearers they
usually have the traditional eagle staff
the eagle staff represents the
importance of honoring and recognizing
the relationship and spiritual
connection to the land of the First
Nations hold in their hearts they also
carry the United States flag in this
case the Chakan Nation Warrior flag and
the P Mia Flags then there would be the
important guests like the royalty tribal
Chiefs or the Elders that come next and
in that group is our girl Maya after her
would be the men dancers and the women
dancers and then the children you know
what's beautiful the way that it's
silent again but instead of the single
heartbeat we get many synchronized
heartbeats with the drum and it's
because she's not alone anymore this is
her family she must protect them it's a
unit God this show gets me crazy I love
my family thank you to better help for
sponsoring this video A new year is a
great excuse for finally tackling stuff
you put off last year and if one of
those things you've been putting off off
until 2024 is taking proper care of your
mental health better he can help you get
started and hey no judgment for waiting
I waited forever starting therapy can be
hard the right therapist for you may not
be in your area and some people struggle
with face Toof face interactions of
therapy your girl does with better help
you can have your therapy sessions as a
phone call or a video chat or even via
messaging if you prefer that whatever is
the most comfortable version of therapy
for you just click the link in the
description and answer a few questions
about what you're looking for from
therapy and what your preferences are
but help will then match you with a
therapist from their Network that's
right for you if you don't really fit
with that therapist which is a common
thing with therapy you can easily switch
to a therapist for no additional cost
without stressing about insurance or
who's in your network or anything like
that if you think you might benefit from
therapy consider betterhelp click the
link in the description or visit
betterhelp.com neww rockstars clicking
that link helps support this Channel and
it helps you get 10% off your first
month of better help so you can connect
with a therapist and see if it helps you
then we get a glimpse of Zay preparing
to ruin everything and pulling up a Yeti
cooler to the top of his RV Maya notices
the Woodpecker and follows the message
once everyone enters the field or the
area of the grand entry we get an
overhead shot of them forming a spiral
and moving in a counterclockwise
rotation I mentioned this in the first
breakdown that the chak Dan shows
reference to the Creator by moving in a
counterclockwise rotation Henry pulls up
fast on the phone with biscuit and
biscuit says this but um there's some
creepy guy here and he brought a whole
bunch of noos in I don't know man
they're up to no good I know it as we
mentioned in episode 2 noos means white
people and let me tell you biscuits got
some good quips about them this episode
not not
Maya wanders into the barn to find
Kingpin who has both Bonnie and Cholla
captive also was it just me or did
anyone else notice in the background the
light drop gesture on Bonnie and Chola
like he's doing this for a stage show I
like this scene with Bonnie translating
from Maya and Kingpin clearly when she
threw away her contact it also lost her
tracker so they lost track of Maya but
they knew she'd come back to save her
family dastardly plan demones plan but
that's Kingpin Kingpin tries to
manipulate her again like he didn't
betray her first and forces Bonnie to
translate how he's going to kill her
family which ised up and a real Kingpin
move when Zane gets to go-ahead to kill
everyone he opens his cooler and we see
a rocket for a rocket launcher or a
rocket grenade whatever the hell also a
Capri Sun a Kool-Aid burst fresa mellow
yellow and a little bit more for when
he's parched after killing a bunch of
people back to Kingpin reacting like a
child who doesn't get his way he orders
his goons to Sucker Punch Ekko and I'm
sure Bonnie was too stunned hearing how
she's about to die to translate this but
also she got her lick back from the
third episode I'm just saying I'm never
going to forget that lick then at this
moment Maya's ancestors began to echo
through her ready to help and be
channeled her mom says Echo and she gets
her name say what you will but when the
characters in the MCU get their name I'm
like I just like it her ancestors stand
behind her which reminds me of the
Phoenix song comic where eka has bonded
with the Phoenix force and it's chosen
her because it's been part of a long
line of her ancestors tucko has a rabbit
sticking gun is still repping the
warrior braids Lok is still wearing her
red paint her full suit is pretty badass
I love the Diamonds the Sun and
forearmed guards kind of reminds me of
shangi I know her outfit represents a
lot of traditional chock tow clothing
but it also looks like a piece of all of
her ancestors lok's red forearms tuo's
belt her mom's necklace is reminiscent
of the Buckle in the sun then chaa from
the first episode matches the bird
symbol of the tattoo Ekko has the same
bird beaded markings on the costume near
her shoulder she's already had a piece
of them the entire time Maya then shares
her powers with her grandma and cousin
and they blow through the goons so the
ancestors can pass it down but also Echo
can distribute it within her family or
just the bloodline then we get the
monster track scene that we saw from the
trailer that turns out to actually be
their grandma's truck that biscuit
remodeled he's currently running over
the noos and I'm sure he killed them all
I'm sure he killed them all while Bonnie
Ekko and Chola are kicking ass Henry
shoots Zayn before he sets off the
explosion on the powwow family
protecting family then like Maya's mom
does to Ekko Ekko goes into the mind of
Kingpin to relieve him of his tortured
trauma this reminds me of the last
episode when he's screaming at her with
the hammer free you free me she has just
in a more you know socially conscious
way and he's clearly not used to that
treatment inside kingpin's abusive
memory he's in his little room with a
New York Yankee sign I think he has a
bunny poster on the wall and if that's
not a call out to the rabbit of a
snowstorm I don't know what is the walls
are painted in chip like the wall his
dad forc him to stare at while he
physically beat his mom it wasn't in the
bedroom but in the living room and the
audio was voiced by different people
than the actors we saw in Daredevil
mayia relieves Kingpin of the trauma
connected to that memory that memory is
why he carries the cufflinks the hammer
the rage and the anger without that I
think we just have a big lug walking
around it would make sense as to why
he's so mad after she's done it he's
lived with that anger his entire life
and now that it's gone that what fuels
that passion to create a better world or
to fix everything and also I don't think
it's necessarily fully gone he wanted to
live with it he was just shocked that
she got into his mind during that
Montage of kingpin's life we see some
new images of young Maya Colin Wilson
uncle and then we get a shot of the
Kingpin from the original Netflix
Daredevil series Kingpin freaks out and
dips before the cops arrive and then we
cut to the lake at Maya's house in the
flashback Maya and her mom released the
Woodpecker who is fully healed and flies
away her ancestors must have been
watching her from that day going forward
on top of the roof we live listen to the
same song When We remain by Samantha Joe
crane the same song that played after
Henry agreed to help Maya in episode 3 a
song written in the chu tow language a
song that the writer said I wanted to
write a chakov version of something like
the old protest song We Shall Overcome
something we could sing through our
hardships and into our victories and
survival as a lasting tribe of people
which in summary is a great song to
conclude the show to as Ekko has
overcome a lot Fisk regret and rage to
find peace in herself and her family she
starts imagining old memories her mom
and dad Scully and Chola the hand
Shadows with Bonnie Maya takes her bike
to cholas where biscuit Bonnie and Henry
sit listening to his story Maya arrives
to visit we don't know if she's staying
there or not I want to assume she does
but I like how this ends kind of like
She-Hulk both families just enjoying a
barbecue then we see Fisk still
traumatized he's on his private plane
going back to New York they say they
must stabilize the situation before it
spirals out of control then we get a
news report from Patrick Kieran of New
York 1 he's appeared also in the first
Avengers movie Hawkeye Spider-Man far
from home but also Daredevil the
Defenders and The Punisher the other
host is Errol Lewis of New York one as
well so remember how I was like Fisk is
doing this all because of his dad his
mission in Daredevil was allegedly to
clean up the city he believed he was
doing the right thing even at the
expense of doing everything illegal and
completely wrong so these key sentences
the voters want somebody who's a fighter
legit problems in the city and voters
want somebody who understands their pain
a bare knuckled brawler this is
completely set up for Kingpin to run for
mayor and we get May fisk's Charles sule
comic story line This is the story line
for Daredevil born again and it'll be
the political versus illegal Showdown
imagine that Kingpin becomes mayor of
New York and starts a war against
vigilante The Defenders Spider-Man
they'd be dunzo and that's it for my
entire breakdown on Marvel's newest and
first Marvel Spotlight show Echo I like
the idea of Marvel spotlights especially
if it's like this it allows the audience
to sit back because the stakes are not
as high and luckily it's more grounded
at the same time the creatives get the
sandbox to make whatever they want did I
love the cultural representation of
course I did 1,00% you guys know me the
attention to detail the work and the
time put in were absolutely outstanding
I learned so much from this series
series and I love learning this way I
think my only corals which are like the
tiniest notes were in the pacing we
didn't really get enough time to blow
out the rest of the family see what she
did between New York and Oklahoma and
would have loved to really like see Maya
I know her beautiful history and what
molded her values but I really haven't
seen Ekko and depend it yet I think it
has great bones actually no I I think
it's good I think it's fine it should
have just like cooked a little bit more
I wish it would have got like two more
episodes on top of it's five regardless
like black panther was to me this series
is four and represents a lot of other
folks and I want to highlight how
important it is to see yourself in media
and who wouldn't want to see a badass
Native American superhero roundhouse a
full den of goons though I have notes
doesn't mean I don't like Ekko I will
always love Maya Lopez and I can't wait
to see her show up in the Defenders with
that being said I'm done I'm out follow
me on Instagram and Twitter Lulu Clemens
follow new rockstars And subscribe to
new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
you guys I'll see you
later
he